- Okay, that's it.
I am not covering any more Trump news.
No more Trump legal issues. I'm done.
Nope.
Even though this lawsuit
has the potential to destroy
the entire Trump organization,
I'm not gonna do it,
but I know someone who can.
Get me Spencer the scowl owl.
(upbeat music)
- Devon I just wanna say thank you
for letting me talk about a subject,
not a single soul is
tired of hearing about,
and that is Donald Trump's legal problems.
Now of course, asking
a criminal prosecutor
to talk about civil law
is a bit like asking a baseball
player to opine about golf.
After all, we both use sticks
to hit balls a certain distance depending
on the circumstances.
So without further ado, let's get to it.
New York Attorney General
Latisha James has filed a civil
enforcement action against
Donald Trump, Don Junior,
Eric Trump, Ivanka Trump,
the Trump organization,
and other Trump organization officers.
Better luck next time, Tiffany.
It's been a busy summer for
America's favorite ex-president.
His ex-wife died and was
buried on this golf course.
Georgia prosecutors empaneled a grand jury
to consider charges against
him for election tampering.
The Department of Justice
executed a search warrant
to get back documents
Trump was storing in his Florida basement.
Trump Organization CFO, Allen Weisselberg,
pleaded guilty to 15 counts of tax fraud
and the Trump organization
will go on trial next month.
In fact, there are so many legal problems
swirling around the former
president that legal legal has
had to open a special Trump
unit just to monitor them all.
Today, we'll explore the legal
basis for the New York State
civil enforcement action against Trump.
And while the New York Attorney General
case is a civil matter,
the case rests on Trump
and the rest violating criminal laws.
What's more, the members
of the Trump organization
have invoked their Fifth
Amendment right against
self-incrimination in a
related criminal prosecution.
All of that brings this
case into my arena,
but more on that later.
First, we need to start with
quite a bit of background.
The complaint alleges that for a decade,
Donald Trump and the Trump
organization knowingly
and intentionally created more
than 200 false and misleading
valuations of assets on his
annual statements of financial
condition in order to defraud
financial institutions.
During the investigation, Mazars,
Trump's longtime accounting firm cut ties
with the Trump organization.
In February of 2020,
Mazar's announced that
his financial statements,
it prepared between 2010 and 2021,
could no longer be relied upon.
The withdrawn statements
formed the backbone
of the state's lawsuit.
The complaint alleges that Donald Trump
and other defendants engaged in conduct
meant to mislead Mazar's in
connection with its work,
compiling the statements.
Because Mazar's was not conducting
any review or audit procedures,
but rather was issuing a compilation,
in which Mr. Trump's and
the trustees assertions
were being compiled into
financial statement format,
many of the fraudulent statements
and strategies remained
concealed from or undetected by Mazars.
The Attorney general contends
that the Trump organization
committed fraud for at least
a decade involving conduct
across more than 23 different
properties and other assets.
When valuing Trump properties,
the company would change
methodology on how to value
properties from year to year
or even within the same year.
Some of the fraud was
allegedly accomplished through
sophisticated accounting, slight of hand,
but other acts were apparently
blatant and easy to detect.
For example, Trump estimated
that his own triplex
apartment in Trump Tower,
was 30,000 square feet,
when it was actually
about 11,000 square feet.
- I always call it massive.
Sometimes they say huge.
- In 2015, Trump valued that apartment
at $327 million in total or
about $29,738 per square foot.
Now that price is absurd,
since at that point only one
apartment in New York City had ever sold
for a hundred million dollars or more,
and that sale was a newly
built ultra tall tower.
No apartment in the 30 year
old Trump Tower was ever sold
for more than 16.5 million.
Between 2011 and 2015,
the value of the triplex
incorporated into the statements
of financial condition
increased more than 400%,
from $80 million to $327 million.
The bulk of this
fraudulently inflated value
came from the misrepresentation
that the apartment was 30,000 square feet.
A property appraiser visited
the penthouse in 2010,
as part of the underwriting
process for an insurance policy.
He noted that his visit to
the triplex was a bit unusual.
This was a unique appraisal appointment.
Before the site visit,
I was told there would be only 15 minutes
to see the apartment.
Mr. Trump was home at
the time of the appraisal
and wanted to do the walkthrough himself.
I was unable to see the master bedroom
and Mrs. Trump's dressing
room per request of Mr. Trump,
Mrs. Trump was sleeping.
Although I was able to
spend slightly longer
than the 15 minutes in the house,
the appointment was conducted at a speed
directed by Mr. Trump and
there was not ample time
to take measurements while on site.
Only after Forbes published
an article in May, 2017,
entitled Donald Trump has been lying
about the size of his penthouse,
did the Trump organization stop inflating
the square footage for the apartment?
The complaint is over 300
pages and contains numerous
examples of Trump allegedly
using various deceptive schemes
in valuing his golf clubs
to inflate their values.
And I'm not talking about the
values of the actual clubs,
but of the clubs where golf takes place.
The statements do not list separate values
for each of the clubs facilities.
Instead, the values for those properties
are lumped together into a single figure.
This was done intentionally
to conceal significant swings
in the value attributed
to individual clubs
and to conceal the methods used
to arrive at those values.
For example, the Office
of the Attorney General
claims that Mar-a-Lago was valued
as high as $739 million
based on the false premise
that it was unrestricted property
and could be developed and
sold for residential use.
Even though Trump himself
signed deeds donating his
residential development rights
sharply restricting changes
to the property and
limiting the permissible use
of the property to a social club.
In reality, the club
generated annual revenues
of less than 2$5 million
and should have been valued
at closer to $75 million.
And this is what brings us
to the New York Attorney
General's Civil Enforcement Action.
The New York Office of the
Attorney General filed a civil
complaint alleging seven
causes of action against Trump
and his co-defendants for violating
New York's executive law.
The state is seeking dramatic remedies,
including the discouragement
of 250 million in Trump
organization profits,
the cancellation of business
certificates for Trump's
corporate entities and
a five year ban on Trump
and his company from entering
into any New York commercial
real estate transactions.
Tish James also wants to
ban Trump and his associates
from applying for loans
from any New York entity
and to stop them from serving
as an officer or director
of a New York corporation.
This would effectively destroy
the Trump organization.
All seven causes of action
are brought under New York
Executive Law Section 63 sub 12.
This law authorizes the New
York Attorney General to bring
civil lawsuits to enjoin repeated,
fraudulent or illegal acts or
persistent fraud or illegality
in the carrying on, conducting
or transaction of business.
The law is a broad discovery
tool for prosecutors,
who only need to show a capacity
or tendency to deceive in order
to issue subpoenas before
a complaint is even filed.
Civil penalties include actual damages,
discouragement of profits,
canceling of corporate
certificates and other prohibitions
that would effectively kill
the Trump organization's
ability to do business in New York.
Trump is no stranger to
New York's executive law.
The New York Attorney General's office
used it to sue Trump
University for fraud in 2013.
In that case, the trial court ruled
that Section 63 sub 12 did not give
the Attorney General the ability
to pursue fraud claims only
under the executive law,
without proving that Trump University
violated state fraud statutes.
However, the appellate division
reversed that trial court ruling,
holding that the Attorney
General could use
section 63 sub 12 as a
catchall anti fraud statute.
After the decision,
Trump settled the case.
So thanks to the Trump University case,
the Attorney General
now has an easier route
for proving the Trump
organization committed fraud.
To prove a violation of Section 63 sub 12,
the state only has to show
a pattern of fraudulent
or illegal business actions.
The term fraudulent or
deceptive practices,
generally includes acts
which may be characterized
as dishonest and misleading.
The terms are not limited to
instances of intentional fraud
in the traditional sense.
Now, just to be clear,
James is not criminally prosecuting Trump
and the Trump organization for tax fraud.
James said she has evidence
that Trump and his family
in corporate officers committed crimes
and she referred those
potential cases to the IRS
and to the Manhattan District
Attorney, Alvin Brag.
But at this point, all we're
talking about is a civil case.
The Attorney General says
investigators uncovered over 200
false and misleading valuations of assets
for the 11 statements
covering 2011 through 2021.
Most large corporations
use outside accountants
to compile their financial statements.
The Attorney General says that
Trump rarely hired outside
professionals to prepare
any of the asset valuations
for the statements.
On the rare occasion that the
organization did get outside
advice on how to value the assets,
the Trump's routinely ignored
or contradicted their advice.
For example, an outside appraiser
said the homes Trump could
build on his Aberdeen, Scotland
golf course would result in a net present
value profit of 16 to 19 million euros,
the equivalent of about
18 to $21.5 million.
The Trump organization
allegedly ignored that valuation
and instead valued the land
at more than $300 million in
Trump's financial statements.
The complaint alleges that
Trump and his partners
and children committed persistent acts
of fraud and that all of this occurred
in an atmosphere conducive to fraud,
in which the goal of
increasing Mr. Trump's reported
net worth on the statements was well known
and carried out by his
agents and subordinates.
All of that conduct was
directed toward presenting
misleading statements to
others, including lenders,
insurance companies and
governmental entities.
The acts of fraud alleged here
were repeated, entailing
among other things,
dozens of specific numerical entries
in financial spreadsheets,
dozens of verbal representations
and financial statements
and other fraudulent
and misleading conduct
by the defendants.
The state argues that this
conduct was persistent
and carried out by the same
key players over several years.
Defendant Jeffrey McConney
prepared or supervised
preparation of supporting spreadsheets,
while Alan Weisselberg reviewed
and approved spreadsheets
and as trustee, certified
the statements accuracy.
Donald Trump reviewed
and approved statements
and certified their accuracy.
Don Jr. certified the statements
accuracy as a trustee.
Ivanka was involved in
numerous real estate deals
in America and overseas.
The defendants allegedly
used this false information
year after year relying on prior year's
information to prepare new valuations,
continuing the use of
deceptive wording in describing
valuations performed and
continuing deceptive strategies
used in the prior year's statements.
So what about the
defendant's mental state?
Unlike many of the
state's anti fraud laws,
the executive law does not
require an intent to defraud.
The test to determine
whether a representation
is false is in its capacity to deceive.
So what acts go to their
capacity to deceive?
The Attorney General says that
each defendant played a role
in certifying false statements
about the Trump organization
and its properties and that
they conspired with each other
to mislead lenders and insurers.
The Trump organization gave
allegedly false statements
to banks to induce those institutions
to rely on fake numbers.
Defendants also went to great lengths
to conceal their fraud.
When they submitted financial
information to Mazars,
the Trump's allegedly
excluded key information,
such as lender ordered appraisals
on a given property or limitations
on development like
the easements on Marla.
By doing this,
defendants hid the correct
valuation of individual
properties by grouping them
together into categories
like club facilities
and related real estate.
The complaint alleges that the defendants
also actively engaged in deception,
such as failing to disclose
the 30% brand premium,
were avoiding the creation
of written records.
When Donald and Eric were
developing the Seven Springs Club,
Mr. Trump and his agents
sought to avoid creating
a documentary record.
Mr. Trump advised his employee
handling his real estate affairs
in the lower Hudson Valley,
which included Seven Springs,
that he did not want communications
between them put in writing
and this ladies and gentlemen
is what we call a clue.
The second cause of action
alleges that the defendant's
committed repeated fraud
or illegality by falsifying
business records in
violation of state law.
Under New York Penal Law section 175.05,
falsifying business records
is committed when with intent
to defraud a person A, makes
or causes a false entry
in the business records of an enterprise.
B, alters erases, obliterates, deletes,
removes or destroys a true
entry in the business records
of an enterprise,
C, omits to make a true
entry in the business
records of an enterprise in
violation of a duty to do so,
which he knows to be
imposed upon him by law
or by the nature of his position.
Or finally D, prevents
the making of a true entry
or causes the emission thereof
in the business records of an enterprise.
The suit alleges that
the Trump organization
kept two sets of books,
one that overvalued properties
when the business sought
loans from banks and another
one that undervalued properties
for tax purposes.
This is a classic fraud.
For example, Trump Park Avenue
is one of the crown jewels in the Trump
real estate empire.
Its value allegedly rose
from $90.9 million in 2011
to $350 million in 2021.
Unsold residential condominium
units owned by Trump
or the company represented
the lion's share
of the reported value
for this property in excess
of 95% in some years.
So what's the catch?
Well, these were actually
rent controlled units
and outside bank ordered appraisal
in 2010 valued the 12 rent stabilized
units at just $750,000 total.
Trump allegedly withheld this appraisal
from Mazars and never told Mazars
the units were subject to rent control.
In the 2020 appraisal,
the value of those units
rose to $85 million,
but the Trump financial statements
said that they were valued at 135 million.
A lead accountant who was
involved in the matter testified
that he was shocked by the
size of the discrepancy
and would never have issued
the financial statements
if he had been aware of the
2010 and 2020 appraisals
and the rent control restriction.
This is a classic two
sets of books situation.
The lawsuit says that all
of the defendants issued
false financial statements
in violation of penal law
section 175.45.
A person issues a false
financial statement
under section 175 45,
when the person with intent fraud, one,
knowingly makes or utters
a written instrument
which purports to describe
the financial condition
of some person and which is inaccurate
in some material respect or two,
represents in writing
that a written instrument
purporting to describe a
person's financial condition,
as of a particular date,
is accurate with respect
to such person's current
financial condition,
knowing it is materially
inaccurate in that respect.
The state alleges that all
defendants acted with intent
to defraud knowingly made or
uttered materially inaccurate
written instruments purporting
to describe Donald Trump's
financial condition.
For example, Trump's 212 acres
Seven Springs property
consists of two large homes,
undeveloped land and
a few other buildings.
An appraisal prepared by the
Royal Bank of Pennsylvania
in 2000 estimated the as
is value of Seven Springs
at $25 million for residential development
and bank records show
that value rose to 30 million in 2006.
- Even the heating vents are
recessed under three inches
of marble with small little
slits cut out of them.
- However, between 2011 and 2021,
valuations of Seven Springs ranged
from 261 million to 291 million.
Why?
Because the financial statements
were based on projections
by Eric Trump who said that
he'd gotten approval to build
seven luxurious mansions on the property.
The lawsuit alleges that Eric
inflated the value of Seven
Springs by exaggerating
development potential
and failing to account for the years
of work that were needed
to make it happen.
The implication of such evaluation
is that the lots or homes
were ready to sell and
would do so instantaneously.
A false and misleading and
indeed impossible assumption.
Eric also allegedly worked to
get a federal tax deduction
by arranging a so-called
conservation easement donation
that was based on an
inflated value for the land.
His attempt to get a conservation
easement was a recognition
that the Trump organization
would never be able to develop
the property for anything
approaching a $161 million return.
Moving on to insurance fraud,
the complaint alleges that the defendants
all committed insurance fraud.
New York Penal Law Article
176.05 defines insurance fraud
as a fraudulent insurance
act committed by any person
who knowingly and with intent to defraud
presents to an insurer, one,
want any written statement
in support of an application
for the issuance of commercial
or personal insurance that he or she knows
to A, contain materially false information
concerning any fact material
or conceal for the purpose
of misleading information concerning
any fact material or two,
any written statement or
other physical evidence
as part of the issuance of
a health insurance policy
or a claim for payment services
or other benefit pursuant to such policy,
contract or plan that
he or she knows to A,
contain materially false information
concerning any material fact or B,
conceal for the purpose of misleading
information concerning any fact material.
The complaint says that
all defendants prepared
and presented written statements
and support of applications for insurance
knowing they contained materially false
information concerning facts
material to those applications.
It alleges the defendants also
concealed facts from insurers
for the purpose of
misleading those insurers.
The lawsuit provides details
on two insurance scenarios
where Aon Risk Solutions was
the broker and the Trumps
are alleged to have
submitted false information,
a surety bond program
with Zurich North America
and directors and officers
liability coverages
from Everest National
and Tokyo Marine HCC.
The Trump financial
documents were key components
in its insurance submissions.
They were used to support Trump's
personal guarantee in lieu
of collateral and to misrepresent
the valuations of Trump properties.
According to lawsuit,
the Trump organization only
allowed underwriters to review
Trump's financial statements in person
at Trump organization offices.
The lawsuit alleges that in addition
to submitting false financial statements,
Trump and his organization
failed to disclose
an investigation into
Trump and other employees
that could have affected their ability
to obtain directors and officers coverage.
Attorney General James claims
that the Trump organization
also failed to disclose
that the golf courses listed
in Trump's statements included
a substantial brand premium
baked into the reported valuation.
Under Zurich's underwriting guidelines,
intangible assets like brand
value have to be excluded.
Had the Trump organization
disclosed the brand premium,
Zurich would've reduced that valuation.
Finally, the complaint alleges
that the defendants
conspired to break the law.
New York Penal Law Section
105 generally prohibits
a person from entering into a
conspiracy to break the law.
The Attorney General alleges
that defendants are also liable
for persistent and repeated
fraud under Executive Law 63
sub 12 as participants in
a long running conspiracy.
Here, the actions of the the defendants,
including making numerous
false and misleading entries
and emissions in financial
statements and supporting
materials in a similar manner over
the course of more than a
decade and then submitting them
to financial institutions
as certified by Mr. Trump
or as trustees reflect the
existence of an agreement
to commit fraud, within the
meeting of Section 63 sub 12.
The state says that it can
prove that the defendants
committed overacts in
furtherance of the conspiracy
as late as 2019, 2020, 2021 and 2022.
So the New York Attorney General
has said that she can prove it.
To get there and to talk about
what that proof actually entails,
we actually have to talk
about the Fifth Amendment.
Ratified as part of the
Bill of Rights in 1791.
The Fifth Amendment is a
shield against prosecutorial,
overreach and a cornerstone
of American liberty.
The Fifth Amendment provides five distinct
constitutional rights.
One, the right to indictment
by a grand jury for felony charges.
Two, prohibition on double jeopardy,
meaning you can't be tried
for the same crime twice.
Three, the right to a fair trial.
Four, no government seizure of
private property without due
compensation and five,
the right against forced
self-incrimination.
And today we're just
focused on that last one,
the right against self-incrimination.
The Fifth Amendment
provides in relevant part,
no person shall be compelled
in any criminal case
to be a witness against himself.
You've probably heard this
right articulated in say,
Miranda warnings in which the police
are required to tell
suspects in police custody,
you have the right to remain silent.
Anything you say can and
will be used against you
in a court of law.
- You have the right to remain silent
if you give up the right to remain silent,
anything you say can and
will be held against you
in a court of law.
- So when people take the
fifth or plead the fifth,
it means they've invoked this
right against being forced
to give testimony that could expose them
to criminal liability.
The Fifth Amendment's protections
cover not just defendants,
but witnesses in both
civil and criminal settings
at the state and federal level.
However, pleading the fifth
is frequently misunderstood by lay people
and demagogued by politicians,
perhaps most famously
by Donald Trump himself.
- The mob takes the fifth.
If you're innocent,
why are you taking the Fifth Amendment?
- And of course,
as is often the case with
all things Donald Trump,
there's always a tweet of him
saying something in the past
that is the exact opposite
of what he's saying today.
So why are we talking
about the Fifth Amendment?
Because of Trump's deposition.
Even getting Trump to sit for a deposition
was a herculean task.
In January, 2022,
the Trump family filed a
motion to quash the subpoenas,
arguing that ordering
the Trump's to testify,
violated their constitutional rights
because their answers could be
used in the parallel criminal
investigation from the Manhattan
District Attorney's office.
In February, a judge
rejected those arguments
and ordered that the Trump's
sit for the deposition.
That order was affirmed on appeal in May.
Notably, Trump's senior
was also held in contempt
of court and fined $10,000 a day
for failing to respond to a
related subpoena for documents.
The elder Trump resolved this contempt
finding in May after
paying $110,000 in fines.
Trump has long attacked the
legitimacy of the New York
investigation and has even
tried to shut it down.
In December, 2021, Trump and his company
filed a federal lawsuit
requesting the court's
enter an injunction
blocking James's office
from continuing to investigate them.
Trump has also publicly
accused Attorney General James,
who is black, of being racist
and only investigating Trump
out of spite and political ambition.
When James first ran for
Attorney General in 2018,
she vowed to investigate Trump if elected,
comments that Trump has
pointed to as evidence
that this is just another witch hunt.
In May, 2022, a federal judge dismissed
Trump's lawsuit rejecting his claims
that he's being targeted
out of political animus
and allowing the
investigation to continue.
After delaying the deposition for a month,
following the death of Trump's first wife,
Trump finally sat for the deposition.
On August 10th, 2022,
Trump arrived at James's
office in lower Manhattan
in order to comply with
the court order to testify.
But when the deposition began,
the typically loquacious former
president had very little
to say in response to questioning.
A source with knowledge of the deposition,
said that Trump took the
fifth more than 440 times,
declining to answer every
single question, except one.
What is your name?
The reason for this high
number of invocations
is that witnesses who seek to invoke
their Fifth Amendment rights,
must assert the privilege
in response to particular
questions asked or evidence sought.
A preemptive blanket assertion
of the Fifth Amendment
in response to all anticipated
questions is not permitted,
and any delay or failure to
assert one's Fifth Amendment
rights may result in a
waiver of that privilege.
James asked Trump a few
preliminary questions,
but the vast majority of
the deposition was conducted
by our deputy.
According to Trump attorney Ron Fischetti,
Trump repeated the same answer of invoking
his Fifth Amendment right,
not to testify over and over again,
for the nearly four hour deposition.
They asked a lot of questions
about valuations and golf
clubs and all that stuff.
Fischetti told the New York Times,
Fischetti claimed Trump actually wanted
to answer the questions,
but had to be talked out
of it by his attorneys.
He absolutely wanted to testify
and it took some very strong
persuasion by me and some
others to convince him,
Fischetti said.
Now, after this deposition,
Trump posted the
following on Truth Social,
a very professional meeting,
have a fantastic company
with great assets,
very little debt, and lots
of cash, only in America.
Trump also put out a more
fiery formal statement
that called the investigation
the greatest which hunt
in the history of our country,
and accused James of openly campaigning
on a policy of destroying me.
Trump also detailed why he
had a change of heart about
taking the fifth, but in
typical Trumpian fashion,
he said that even though
he is totally innocent,
he had no choice but to plead the fifth
because everyone is corrupt
and out to get him for no reason.
I once asked If you're innocent,
why are you taking the Fifth Amendment?
Now, I know the answer to that question.
When your family, your company,
and all the people in your orbit
have become the targets of unfounded,
politically motivated witch
hunt supported by lawyers,
prosecutors and the fake news
media, you have no choice.
Accordingly, under the
advice of my counsel
and for all the above reasons,
I decline to answer the questions
under the rights and privileges afforded
to every citizen under the
United States Constitution.
Despite Trump's claim
that he had no choice,
he did in fact have a choice.
After all, his daughter,
Ivanka and son Don Jr.
were deposed by the New York
Attorney General's Office
and they answered questions
instead of pleading the fifth.
Also, it might surprise you
to learn that Trump was not being
entirely truthful about his experience
with the Fifth Amendment.
I know, it's hard to believe.
In fact, Donald Trump is quite familiar
with pleading the fifth in
far less serious matters.
During his contentious divorce
with his recently deceased
first wife, Ivana Trump,
Mr. Trump was asked 100
questions from Ivana's lawyers,
over the course of five depositions
that related to marital infidelity.
Trump pleaded the fifth
in response to 97 of them.
Given that the marriage famously
fell apart due to Donald's
tabloid affair with model actress
and future wife Marla Maples,
Mr. Trump likely calculated
he would be better off simply
not answering questions
about set affair than
admitting to it on the record.
And that strategy seems to
have worked well for him,
later bragging that he
managed to settle the divorce
without giving Ivana a penny more
than required by the prenuptial agreement.
And even following Ivana's death,
Trump seemed to relish not
spending a lot of money
on the mother of his adult children.
Now, you might be thinking,
hold on a second,
I thought we were talking
about a civil case
and not a criminal case and
you're absolutely right.
So let's go back to the complaint.
New York civil fraud complaint
makes repeated references to
Donald Trump, son Eric Trump,
and former Trump CFO, Alan Weisselberg,
repeatedly invoking the Fifth Amendment.
In Latisha James's press conference
announcing the civil suit,
the New York Attorney General
also cited Weisselberg
and Trump seniors invoking
the Fifth Amendment,
when asked about their
potentially fraudulent activities.
The implication of James's
references is that the defendants
had the opportunity to defend themselves
from allegations of fraud,
but repeatedly chose not to,
suggesting consciousness of guilt.
But like most things
involving Donald Trump,
the New York investigation
has inspired commentators
to adopt some very bad legal takes.
Like for example, senior Fox
business editor Jay Caruso,
who tweeted invoking
Constitutional rights is evidence
of committing a crime, great precedent.
Now, Caruso Snark aside,
he's actually just making an
incorrect statement of the law.
And I know, I know,
a Fox News personality saying something
demonstrably inaccurate is
the first time for everything.
When someone pleads the
fifth in a criminal setting,
prosecutors may not comment
on a defendant's refusal
to testify as evidence of guilt,
nor may a jury be instructed
to interpret a defendant's
silence as a sign of guilt.
In Griffin v. California,
the US Supreme Court ruled
that prosecutors may not use
the defendant's refusal to testify
as substantive evidence of guilt,
as doing so would illegally
penalize defendants
for availing themselves
to the Fifth Amendment's
Constitutional protections.
Even though prosecutors can't
use defendant silence against
them in criminal cases,
that same silence or refusal to answer,
can have severe consequences
in a civil context.
That's because in both
a private civil case
and a state civil enforcement action,
a judge or jury can draw
adverse inferences to support
liability when the defendant
invokes the Fifth Amendment,
something that is absolutely not permitted
in criminal cases.
This principle was articulated
by the Supreme Court
in Baxter v Palmigiano.
The Fifth Amendment does not
forbid adverse inferences
against parties to civil actions,
when they refuse to testify
in response to probative
evidence offered against them.
The amendment does not
preclude the inference
where the privilege is claimed
by a party to a civil cause.
In an August 10th, 2022,
interview with MSNBC,
lawyer and former FBI
special agent Asha Rangappa
explained just how devastating
taken to fifth could
be for Trump against a
civil enforcement action.
- In a criminal case,
a jury cannot draw inferences
of guilt from someone
asserting their Fifth Amendment right.
But in a civil case,
a jury can draw an adverse
inference and there's a lower
standard of proof.
It's a preponderance of the evidence.
And in that, in a civil case though,
what Trump is facing are
potential financial penalties.
- Other legal commentators have noted
that while pleading
the fifth helps protect
the Trumps from criminal liability,
that same refusal to answer
questions leave them quite
vulnerable to James's civil action.
Former federal prosecutor,
Renato Marioti wrote as much on Twitter.
The New York AG has a lot
of leverage in this lawsuit
because Trump and his son Eric,
took the fifth hundreds of times.
That was smart to do,
but it means they're
screwed in the civil case.
A jury would likely be instructed
to presume their answers
would have hurt Trump.
In short, the reason Caruso's statement
is legally incorrect is
that it fails to note
the distinction between invoking
your Fifth Amendment rights
in a criminal context
versus a civil setting.
And in that respect,
James isn't creating new precedent,
so much as she's relying on case law
that's existed for nearly 50 years.
And when Caruso's misstatement
of law was pointed out
by National Security lawyer
Bradley P. Moss on Twitter,
Caruso responded with
the grace and contrition,
we've come to expect from Fox News.
By which I mean none at all.
So that's it.
That is the legal basis for
the New York State civil
enforcement action against Donald Trump,
the Trump organization, his kids,
and a bunch of other randos.
So on behalf of the legal,
legal special Trump unit and Dev Insanity,
I just wanna say please,
for the love of God,
can we just end this insane news cycle?
Oh God, that's terrible.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Special Trump unit with
the 24 hour news cycle
just can't die.
Oh, no, no, not again.
Not again, not another one.
- No, no, we can't.
Because of Letitia James's
rights, as we discussed,
she'll use the indications
of the Fifth Amendment
to destroy the Trump organization,
and they were about to be
a whole bunch of Trump org
employees and middle-aged
Trump adult children
that are out of a job.
And of course, they
could all really benefit
from today's sponsor, 80,000 hours.
80,000 hours is a nonprofit,
helps people find
careers that aim to solve
the world's most pressing problems.
Have you ever taken a career
aptitude test where they just
ask you to list a bunch of preferences
and then it tells you to be
like a structural engineer
and you feel confused about
what is based on and what
you've been recommended?
I know I took tons of those
and none of them
recommended YouTube lawyer,
and that's because most career
advice is cookie cutter,
and it focuses on a few
mainstream and obvious paths
and doesn't take into account
the best available evidence about
how to actually find a fulfilling career.
And most importantly,
relevant career advice
can be really hard to find
if you care a lot about making a big,
positive difference in the world.
And many sources on this topic
only recommend a few well
known career paths that people often think
have a high social impact.
Like, I don't know,
being a doctor, teacher,
charity worker, boo.
No, those are great,
but those aren't your only options
and they probably aren't
even your best options.
80,000 Hours is a nonprofit
that aims to help you find
a career that is both fulfilling
and makes a big positive difference.
The name comes from the number of hours,
an average career take 40 hours a week,
50 weeks a year for 40 years.
That's a lot of time,
and that means that your
career is probably the biggest
opportunity to have an impact.
80,000 Hours has done over 10
years of research alongside
academics at Oxford University.
It's a how to find a fulfilling career
that does a lot of good,
and it turns out that the
best way to make a positive
difference might be pretty
different from what you'd think.
And they always try to avoid
platitudes and unsupported
generalizations.
In fact, all of their recommendations
are based on careful research
and consultation with
experts in relevant fields.
And when they aren't sure
of something, they say so.
So if you care about what the
evidence actually says about
having a fulfilling and impactful career,
than 80,000 hours can help.
Plus everything they
provide is free forever.
Because they're a nonprofit.
Their only aim is to help solve
global problems by helping
people find the most
impactful careers they can.
So this one is a no brainer
if you're thinking about your career.
If you'd like a free copy of 80,000 Hours
in Depth Career Guide,
that helps you learn about what makes
for a high impact career, get
new ideas for impactful paths,
and makes a new plan based
on what you've learned,
then just click on the
link in the description
or on the screen right now,
you'll get access to their
free newsletter with updates
on their research and high
impact job opportunities.
Again, all you have to
do is click on the link
that's in the description
or on screen right now
to start planning for a career
that is meaningful, fulfilling,
and help solve some of the
world's most pressing problems.
And after that,
click on this link over
here for More Legal Eagle,
or I'll see you in court.